welcome back to S a school teacher in
Massachusetts United States who uses
Harry Potter in his storytelling course
has gone viral of his response to a
student questioning about JK Rowling
supposedly transphobia Warren Smith was
asked do you still like her work despite
her bigoted opinions what happened next
was a very Swift and forensic lesson in
critical thinking let's define bigoted
opinions what opinions are bigoted live
your best life do you find that trans
I'm just going with what a lot of other
people have said at the beginning of
this conversation you said given the
fact that JK Rowling is transphobic how
do you feel about Harry Potter I feel
like an idiot
now well after the video was shared by
Elon Musk it's now been viewed over 40
million times on musk's platform x with
tens of thousands of comments heaping
Praise on Warren for his master class
and how to think for yourself and Warren
Smith joins me now from Massachusetts uh
Warren well first of all congratulations
on having one of the biggest viral uh
things I've watched all year secondly
are you surprised um because it's it's
really captured I think a mood of people
desperate to see teachers behaving this
way where you didn't take a position you
simply laid everything out and let the
student reach their own
conclusion yeah I am absolutely
surprised by this completely I never
expected this at all this came
out accidentally just we have
interactions like this on a daily basis
this one just happened to be captured on
camera um we were conducting a an a
broadcast at school I teach multimedia
and I teach students how to work with
camera and how to be on camera and the
student was getting cold feet to do the
newscast and so I said I'll show you
it's not difficult we'll do a little
warmup and here I'll just sit here ask
me whatever you want it's just a
conversation what's something
interesting that we could talk about you
know what's on your mind and that's the
question that came out and you saw the
rest unfold it was really fascinating to
watch the student and credit to the
student who was prepared to listen to
you I think because of the the
non-hostile environment you immediately
created uh was able to go on a kind of
Journey of exploration now I've been
crying out for uh schools and
universities to to follow this path
where students can actually debate these
things in a good environment hear other
sides to an argument and reach maybe a
better conclusion than the echo chambers
that fly around fueled by social media
and it was great at the end he sort of
realized in the end there was nothing
really as offensive as he' presumed from
the kind of toxic atmosphere around JK
rowy I think that's why the video
resonated was that you see in real time
a transformation a journey with a
beginning a middle and an end and he
does come to a realization and the
realization is larger than JK Rowling
this is about more than JK Rowling it's
the realization that he is his prior
assumptions he was going off of well
I've heard that this is true so many
people have told me that this is true
and when you experience that for
yourself and it crumbles then you have
to question logically what else am I
assuming to be true yes that perhaps
might not be and that changes the way
you view the world yeah completely it
been some great reaction uh to you a guy
called Vincent Lindero said let's build
an AI version of this teacher duplicate
him as many times needed and have
everyone learn and understand how to
think think not what to think and a guy
called Lance said interesting I don't
see him dressing with multicolor
garments or weird hair no piercings or
visible tattoos looks in relatively
decent shape in control of the classroom
and discussion is this what the left
calls toxic masculinity because we need
more of it if it
is that's such a coincidence that you
brought up that quote that's the quote
that actually stuck out to me the most
because he said reasonably in shape and
I thought reasonably in shape in what re
in reason to what perhaps we'll provide
some uh critical thinking on that well
trust me compared to me you look in
Olympian shape um what's your message to
to other Educators around the world who
maybe have been heading to a bad place
where they've been almost teaching Dogma
um fueled Again by maybe what x is
saying or what Instagram or Tik Tock is
say what do you say to
them do not be afraid to allow these
ation to occur because these students
have the ability to do what you saw in
that video and to reason their way
through these things and to learn new
ways to advance through life but they
will not be able to do so if not given
the opportunity sometimes it just takes
the right questions just a little bit of
prompting and leading by
example it's pivotal allow them to
happen don't live out of fear not
dissimilar actually to the art of
parenting
I can tell
you I believe you I don't have kids at
the moment yeah I've got four of them
and I can tell you the same strategy
actually works if you just shout at kids
and bark at them and tell them what they
should be thinking and doing I think you
end up with you know kids who are quite
damaged if you allow them the freedom
and the space to reach their own
decisions and conclusions and thought
processes everybody wins um and Talking
of everyone winning or not winning I see
that you agree with me that Barbie
shouldn't have been nominated for a Best
Picture Oscar that just once again shows
you have uh absolutely impeccable taste
Warren well I admire what they were able
to do was extremely creative being able
to do something like that with a movie
about a doll Barbie but the question is
what lens are we examining what do an
Oscar mean what's the lens that we're
looking at this through and I do think
that it comes down to the technical
artistic press that intangible elusive
thing that cannot be replicated with
given enough money given a large enough
budget you can go build a big Barbie
house on a back lot but something like
Braveheart Titanic there certain it's
much difficult much more difficult to
replicate yeah completely um finally you
specialize in Hogwarts Harry Potter my
oldest son is absolutely addicted to
them he can recite all the movies from
the audio books blah blah blah blah blah
I've never watched any of it not my
thing at all but we've got 40 seconds
what is the best life advice you can
give me from all your Harry Potter
studies which will enhance my
life voluntarily accept the unknown and
enter the unknown beneath the surface
perhaps it's the Chamber of Secrets
beneath the the surface of Hogwarts to
face the serpent and save Jenny the
thing that will Ser that will turn you
to Stone when you see it out of fear
perhaps you've got to face it and you
can't be forced to do it you have to do
it voluntarily that's what's going to
make all the difference wow Warren
you've almost you've almost converted me
almost uh Warren Smith great to talk to
you keep up the great work we need more
teachers like you and it's a privilege
to have you on the show you can watch
Warren's full video on X look it out
it's
great